no no no no I like it
smart smirk the lost village is directed
by Kelly Asbury co-director of spirit
stallion of the Cimarron Shrek 2 and the
sole director of Gnomeo and Juliet and
this is the third Smurfs film in six
years but unlike the first two this is
not a direct sequel it's actually a
reboot there are no humans in this movie
no Neil Patrick Harris or Brendan
Gleeson this time it's a fully animated
Smurfs movie in other words this is the
Smurfs movie they should just maze from
the beginning but they didn't I don't
know why I guess they had some tablets
to sell Wow eh Paul does his lesbian
800mm of the bed swiping motion js3
twice so the plot this time around is
that Smurfette is feeling very out of
place because she is not an actual Smurf
she was created out of clay by Gargamel
the evil Dark Wizard and when she learns
of a lost village of undiscovered Smurfs
she sets out with some of her Smurf
buddies to find it and hopefully join
these two teams of Smurfs together in a
battle against the evil Gargamel because
you know Smurfs and their blue and let's
make another one
yay more Smurfs movies I saw this movie
very early because they did one of those
sneak preview things on Saturday where
it was like you could go to a public
theater and pay for a ticket at 4:30 it
was and my wife was like hey let's just
go and see it you can get an early
review out there plus we can see if it's
any better than the other two atrocities
my hatred for the first two Smurfs is
kind of a thing on my channel so I just
had to see this movie I had to know was
it really as bad as the first two or did
they improve it finally do they listen
to the fans of The Smurfs
yes they actually did on both accounts
this is a major improvement on the first
two Smurfs there are no humans there are
no boring legal litigation subplots
there's no Sony Tablet there's no time
Square sequence where every billboard is
about blu-ray or some other Sony product
gracefully this is actually a major
improvement on the first two is it a
good film though I wouldn't really say
my best analogy would probably be the
recent trolls movie a perfectly
acceptable kids movie for very very
young children and they will be
entertained by it and they'll like it
does it push the boundaries or challenge
family entertainment no it's all those
beat for beat the basic formula of every
average children's film there's a big
dance sequence a bunch of jokes that
aren't funny unless you're 5 a whole
bunch of action sequences that really
don't matter they're just there to
entertain kids and there's nothing wrong
with that this is the first theatrical
Smurfs movie I've seen that's not
offensive it's just very bland
it's your run-of-the-mill children's
movie young kids are going to be very
entertained everyone else not so much
which is kind of unfortunate actually
because there are plenty of fans of the
Smurfs today that are in their 30s and
40s because this cartoon and even a
comic strip dates back pretty far and
there's a lot of fans nowadays that are
no longer kids and these films now are
squarely aimed at children and that's
possibly the only reason I can really
find to justify why the first two films
had adults because they were trying to
in some way also cater to the adult fan
of the Smurfs but now this one is a
hundred percent aimed at that elementary
school bracket so people who grew up
with a cartoon in the 80s who are now in
their 30s or 40s are probably not going
to find much to enjoy here this is 100
percent for young kids if you have a kid
in elementary school you can probably
take them to this and they'll be
perfectly entertained by it if you're an
adult you can probably watch it and find
nothing that's going to offend you but
beyond that there's really nothing
special about this movie it has some
entertaining moments the characters are
basically just amalgamations or whatever
their name is which that's just the
Smurfs that's what the Smurfs have
always been there's nothing too
mind-blowing about the Smurfs they're a
bunch of basically seven dwarf knockoffs
that are blue and they do things based
off their name so if you hated the first
two like I did you'll probably view this
one as a step up from those but beyond
that there's really nothing special
about this movie at all
I'm going to get Smurfs the locked
village of C considerably better than
the others but there are far better
family films to show your kids than this
one this is basically one of those
babysitting movies you put it on your
kids entertain for 90 minutes and they
don't cry they don't do anything we
don't run around they don't break
anything they're watching Smurfs The
Lost village and it's entertaining them
that's basically what this movie is for
beyond that you don't really have to see
it guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to my reviews of
ghost in the shell' and also seeing a
screening of gifted this week which I'm
really excited for thank you so much
guys you're the best and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]